gonna kick it off with an amazing story
from atlanta
i personally made sure we told this
story today because
it just did everything for me that i was
looking for
cnn reports that the city has launched
the largest
community food forest in the country
it's in browns mill neighborhood and
it's 7.1
acres and it provides over 2 000 edible
and medicinal plants to the community
onions
garlic potatoes tomatoes so much fresh
free food and one in four atlanta
residents live in areas called
food deserts because they lack basic
access to
affordable and nutritious food so this
forest
is a huge resource and it's a community
center and it's run by 1
000 volunteers and for many young
students
it'll be their first trip to a farm and
there are 70
free food forests in the united states
so far
ross the reason that i was so passionate
about this is because
you want to see the evidence of
something magical
and change and this is it for me
well and it's also just like the
baseline of how we should be helping
each other there are hungry people
who need food right and this sort of
food forest
provides that for people it is so simple
that we can take care of each other
this easily right we grow it and i grew
up in an agricultural farm town my first
job was picking
spinach then i sold berries i used to
say have a very good day
but of course you were probably like
four yeah
i was super chip i always wore a gingham
and i actually bought overalls at a
thrift store
but the part thank you but it gave me
such an appreciation
for food and i think it's why i love to
cook now so i love that not only
the volunteers providing this food for
the people that need it but they're
bringing
kids there to show them how it's done
and to show literally you can plant a
seed
and plant a seed of a good deed at the
same time
these are the kinds of things where i
think i sit around and fantasize about
the
what the world could be and it is and it
is it is it is a nice reminder and next
we've got a little bit of cardi
b news yahoo life reports that cardi
just announced she has a brand new
cardi b doll and she designed it all
herself in collaboration with
real women r which is a doll company
that's dedicated to diversity and
inclusion cardi says she never saw a
doll that looked like her growing up
and she was inspired by her two-year-old
daughter culture and her nieces and you
can pre-order the cardi b
doll now now did you ever play with
dolls drew
you know i did have some barbies for
sure but
my big thing was matchbox cars and i
collected them and i had like a little
recipe box
and they were all uh on index cards like
their color their make
like you know the green pinto type of
thing well
i think it's great that she's making
this doll because she didn't have it
growing up you know i i didn't have well
i would like to say i didn't have a doll
that didn't
that i did have a doll that looked like
me because i had a cabbage patch kid i
asked i asked three christmases and i
finally got it and look there i am
that's me oh no don't i look like oh
cute i look like a walking living
cabbage patch kid
i always like there see look at look at
me not so bad
kid right that's what i was thinking i
love him
and you thanks so much my cabbage patch
kids name was randy
of course it was yeah he came with her i
would never have chosen no offense to
all the randy's out there watching well
if you're feeling randy
i love that name for that reason because
it has a double entendre
all right um next we're always looking
for ways to shop more consciously and
now just in time for women's history
month there's a new way to do it
a collaborative called empower at work
does
amazing work all around the world
educating and empowering the women
who power the fashion industry it would
not exist without
them and they provide the tools to
garment workers
in countries across asia and africa and
now you can
directly contribute to their work vogue
reports that you can now find the
fashion makes the change roundup button
when you check out at 40 different major
fashion retailers
across the u.s or you're checking out
online
you can now donate any amount of change
you have in your pockets or dollars
whatever it is it will go directly to
these women macy's nordstrom michael
kors are just a few of the brands
that are participating there's so many
on this list
and i think knowing what this is going
to is really important so that we can be
familiar and be like yes this is going
directly to these women who make clothes
yeah and you think okay so around let's
say it's 14 90 i say round up to 15
you're like what's 10 cents going to do
but if we all start chipping in 10 cents
we can make
we can raise some real money for these
women i completely agree
and that's the point well and when we're
not shopping or shopping online you know
what we're doing we're streaming and a
lot of people
they're going to going to go back and
re-watch some old favorites
and if you're thinking of re-watching
friends well now is the perfect time let
me explain
apartment therapy reports a website
called best value schools
will pay you a thousand dollars just to
watch the first
five seasons of friends now why they're
picking five people for the job and
here's how you qualify
you have to love friends you have to be
ready to document your experience on
social media
and you can apply on the best value
schools website through march 31st
um and i think it's just because you
know people are relating to that song
right now
no one said your life was going to go
this way
yeah you know if you can relate to that
song uh here's a little
help for you we're going to pay you just
to watch friends i mean
this is a couch potatoes dream do you
think i could find a gig
if they could uh pay me to watch golden
girls because i could do that all day
every day
yeah you and a lot of people i know um
well friends ran for 10 seasons
and we all remember those iconic sets
look at who got to
visit the friends set this one's
monica's kitchen
oh my gosh yeah it's the shed aquarium
penguins
i started watching this and i just got
lost in a trance
and it's like it's just so cute why is
it so cute rossy
remember that time you had a weird dream
about penguins on the set of friends oh
no
that was reality look why does this just
make me happy
i don't know but i could watch it all
day long look at him go
all right well that's it for drew's news
[Music]
you